WOULD NOT BUT THE SENATE EXPECTS
TO BE OPEN FOR BUSINESS
5TH OF MAY NEXT WEEK.
STAY TUNED FOR MORE ON THAT.
ALSO PRELIMINARY DATA SHOWS THAT
PATIENTS WHO RECEIVE REMDESIVIR
HAVE A 31% FASTER RECOVERY TIME
THAN THOSE WHO TOOK A PLACEBO.
DR. MARC SIEGEL, FOX NEWS
MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT.
I’VE GOT A LOT OF QUESTIONS HERE
AND LET’S SEE HOW MUCH GROUND WE
CAN PLOW IN THE NEXT FEW
MINUTES.
REMDESIVIR, HOW DOES IT WORK,
WHAT’S THE COMPONENT OR WHAT IS
IN THIS COCKTAIL?
>> REMDESIVIR IS AN INTRAVENOUS
DRUG AND IN THIS CASE, IT WAS
TRIED IN 1,000 PATIENTS THAT
WERE ALREADY VERY SICK AND HAD
PNEUMONIA, AND THAT WAS IN 68
CENTERS AROUND THE WORLD.
GOING TO TRY IT, WE WILL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS EARLIER BUT HERE’S
HOW IT WORKS, BASICALLY A VIRUS
GOES INSIDE YOURSELF.
HIJACKS YOUR DNA AND YOUR
MACHINERY TO REPLICATE.
ALL THAT CARES ABOUT IS
REPRODUCING AND THEN JUMPING TO
ANOTHER CELL.
REMDESIVIR IS INCORPORATED IN
ONE OF THE ENZYMES THAT THE
VIRUS USES TO REPRODUCE.
AND ONCE IT GETS INSIDE THE
VIRUS, IT HALTS THE
REPRODUCTION.
IT THE VIRUS AND THE VIRUS
HALTS.
THAT IS AN INCREDIBLE MECHANISM
THAT SEEMS TO DECREASE THE
AMOUNT OF VIRUS THAT IS
CIRCULATING IN YOUR BODY.
IT IS DECREASING FROM 14 DAYS TO
11 DAYS RECOVERY TIME.
THAT’S THE KEY.
>> Bill: DR. FAUCI YESTERDAY
SAID IT’S NOT A KNOCKOUT, BUT IT
LOOKS GOOD.
HOW DO YOU RATE IT?
>> I RATE IN TERMS OF VIRUS
RECOVERY TIME.
IN OTHER WORDS, THAT DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN 14 DAYS AND 11 DAYS IS
HUGE IF YOU’RE TRYING TO RECOVER
FROM A LIFE-THREATENING ILLNESS,
BUT WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IF YOU GIVE IT EARLIER IN
THE GAME.
TO HIM I GOING TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF THE HOSPITAL
WITH IT IF I GIVE IT
INTRAVENOUSLY AT HOME?
IS IT GOING TO SHORTEN HOSPITAL
COURSES?
IS GOING TO SAVE LIVES?
WE DON’T KNOW YET, BUT
PRELIMINARY STUDIES LIKE IT MAY
SAVE SOME LIVES, AND THAT’S KEY.
>> Bill: SO IT STOPS THE VIRUS
FROM REPLICATING IN THE BODY
WHICH STUNS THE GROWTH WHICH IS
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
BUT THEY WERE USING THIS DRUG ON
EBOLA A FEW YEARS AGO.
YOU REMEMBER THAT.
>> YES.
EBOLA IS A FAR DIFFERENT TYPE OF
VIRUS.
EBOLA IS AN INCREDIBLY DEADLY
THIS VIRUS FOR SOME REASON MAKES
A LOT OF INFLAMMATION AND BLOOD
CLOTS IN YOUR BODY.
THAT’S WHEN IT GETS DEADLY.
WITH THIS VIRUS, I THINK YOU CAN
STOP IT IN ITS TRACKS A LOT
EASIER THAN EBOLA.
ONCE A BULLOCK GETS IN THERE,
IT’S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO DEFEAT
IT.
>> Bill: IF THIS IS THE
ANSWER, AND I STILL NOTE SOME
HESITATION IN THE ANALYSIS HERE
FROM MEDICAL EXPERTS LIKE
YOURSELF, GILEAD IS GOING TO
HAVE TO PRODUCE HOW MUCH OF
THIS?
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOSES
AND HOW DIFFICULT COULD THAT BE
TO GET IT PRODUCED AND GET IT
OUT ALL OVER THE WORLD?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DON’T KNOW
THAT’S THE ANSWER.
WHAT I THINK IS IT’S A WEAPON.
IT’S DEFINITELY AN ARROW IN OUR
QUIVER.
IT’S A TOOL WE HAVE NOW.
IT’S GOING TO SAVE LIVES I
BELIEVE.
GILEAD IS GOING TO START BY
RAMPING UP 100,000 TREATMENT
COURSES OVER THE NEXT MONTH AND
BY THE END OF THE YEAR, MILLIONS
OF COURSES.
SO THEY ARE ON THE WAY TO MAKING
MILLIONS OF DOSES OF THIS.
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING TO BE
NEEDED.
BUT EVEN 100,000 DOSES TO BE
USED TREATMENT COURSES IS GOING
TO MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
I THINK IT’S SOMETHING POSITIVE
HERE.
>> Bill: ARE YOU GIVING IT A
A, B, WHAT ARE YOU GIVING IT
RIGHT NOW?
LOOKING FOR HELP, BE HONEST.
>> IT IS PRELIMINARY.
I’M GIVING IT AN A-.
I AM VERY EXCITED -- HERE’S THE
REAL HEADLINE.
CLINICAL TRIALS DONE THIS
QUICKLY WITH RESULTS ON 1,000
PATIENTS THIS QUICKLY THAT SHOW
A POSITIVE RESULT, WOW.
AGAINST A DEADLY VIRUS, THIS IS
INCREDIBLE.